(light electronic music)
- Hey, come on in.
Yes, Push & Believe, you got it.
I want to call you Gabe Liberman
- Do it.
- And that's not right.
- It's not the wrongest
that people have said it.
- It's Gabe Lieberman
or Gay Lieberman?
- Nope.
- I messed up and I
didn't mean to go there.
I did not mean to go there,
that's unprofessional.
- I'm going off of vibes
and I know that you're
not a homophobe and
you don't hate me
- No!
- So you can say whatever.
- When did you
know you were gay?
- Early, I knew I was gay
when I was like six or seven.
- So I like women, I'll
sit at a coffee house
and I see an attractive
woman and I appreciate that
and I'm attracted
her, is that a sign
of being a straight male?
- Yeah, I would say
that's the sign.
- Hi.
- So that's kind
of slightly gay.
- Yes, that is pretty gay.
- I'm 10% gay.
- You are?
- Yes.
- That's a lot to admit.
- That's a lot of
percentage points?
- No, just that
you're any amount gay.
As a straight guy, I
think it's a lot to admit
that you're even a little gay.
- People have picked on me,
oh Brody, you walk weird.
You gay, you gay.
- Do you walk gay?
- Brody, you gay.
- You walk gay?
- I mean, I don't
want to kiss a guy,
I don't want to hand hold a guy,
hug a man, but that's
as far as it goes.
- That's 10% gay, hugging?
- No, then I factor
in the internet.
- Oh, gotcha.
- Look at you and your posing.
- My ankle?
- How do I get there?
- Ankle to knee, ankle to knee
and then if you reach forward,
touch the ground, feel that?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, rips your butt up.
- Alright, Gabe,
what's another pose?
- If you just go like
this and sit on the block.
- Here we go, here we go.
- Just sit on back.
- And sit on it?
- Yeah.
- Now what do I
do once I'm back?
- You just breathe.
- Neck rotations?
- Yeah, sure, that feels great.
You can reach up, that'll
be your core a little.
- What else?
- Side, you could
- Gabe, guide me.
- Side to side,
that's obliques there.
- Bring me back up, what else?
- Reach back.
- Grasp my hands.
- Your actual
hands, there we go.
There you go.
(laughter)
How are those jeans?
- Stretching, I'm gonna
sit back down on the block
- There you go.
- Wow, that gave me a
head rush in a good way.
Let's wrap it up.
- Let's wrap it up.
- Let us wrap it up
with some kettlebells.
I'm gonna get up, push, drive,
everything is from the hips.
- [Gabe] Okay.
- I'm gonna grab a 20 right
here, here's a fiver for you,
no disrespect
- None Taken.
- And I just take
these and I hold them
and I drive, I drive.
You use and you drive up
like when I go down like this
hips out, push,
down, out,
push, believe,
you got it.
Drive it up
- That feels good.
- Push, that's functional.
Gabe, yoga, positivity.
- I never do that right, yeah!
- Whew, yeah!
I'm the Lance Armstrong of
the Comedy Central videos
and I'm sitting on my
testicle right now.
Subscribe, comment, like me,
DM me, Tweet me, send me an IM,
follow me home one night,
pedal with me to
Twitter, to Facebook,
like the videos.
You wanna go bike
riding with me?
Do what it takes, go live!
(slurping)